merci Philippe de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure être
élu de la manchement du groupe les
républicains et on va commencer en
parlant de la réforme des retraites
elisabethes qui a donc déclaré hier lors
des questions d'actu que le gouvernement
a déposé un amendement pour les 20-21
ans qui posent le principe que dès lors
qui est atteint l'âge de départ
anticipait la réforme ne prévoit pas
pour les carrières longues de durée de
cotisation supérieure à 43 ans c'est un
nouveau pas vers les républicains c'est
en tout cas un pas vers ce qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt et qui ne
doivent pas avoir l'obligation de
travailler 45 ans 46 ans pour atteindre
l'âge de la retraite à tout plein et je
crois que quand on fait une réforme
comme celle-ci
pour nécessaire qu'elle soit et qui nous
rapproche d’ailleurs de ce qui est la
règle dans tous les pays européens
regardez un peu au-delà de nos
frontières bien quand on fait une
réforme comme celle-ci l'impératif de
justice doit évidemment être au cœur du
dispositif
cette réforme dans cette impératif de
justice parce que là les 17 ans devons
cotiser 43 ans mais ceux qui ont
commencé à 16 ans doivent toujours
cotiser 44 ans c'est un problème pour
vous c'est-à-dire que en réalité il y a
un moment où les mesures d'équilibrage
ne doivent pas être tels qu'elles en
viennent à mettre en péril l'intérêt de
la réforme pour tous les Français même
cet intérêt est clair ça veut dire que
alors qu'il y a de moins en moins de
cotisants de plus en plus de retraités
qui vivent de plus en plus longtemps on
garantit que à partir d'un certain âge
et d'une certaine durée de cotisations
on aura bel et bien une retraite dont le
montant sera indexé sur les prix c'est à
dire qu'on ne per pas de pouvoir d'achat
comme ça était le cas c'est six
dernières années et ça c'est une
nécessité d'intérêt collectif qui
bénéficie non pas aux gens qui a un gros
patrimoine et qui bien sûr sont heureux
d'avoir une bonne pension de retraite et
surtout aux gens qui vivent
exclusivement de leur pension de
retraite qui payent un loyer etc il faut
il faut être attentif à ce que toutes
les mesures de justice que nous allons
prendre ne soit pas des mesures qui
déséquilibrent la réforme j'ai envie de
vous dire une chose que je crois très
importante
parce que
en matière de réforme des retraites il
n'y a pas le grand soir il y a un
ajustement qui doit se faire
régulièrement pour que les réformes
soient progressives et soit lié à la
situation économique quand il y a une
grande croissance les cotisations
rentrent à flot dans les caisses de
retraite quand il y a du chômage les
cotisations baisse quand il y a beaucoup
de naissances on se dit dans 20 ans
j'aurais des cotisants quand il y a peu
de naissance etc quand il y a beaucoup
d'immigrations quand il y a peu
d'immigrations et pour ceci il faut
régulièrement prendre des mesures si on
ne l'a pas fait pendant plus de 10 ans
comme ça était le cas alors on se
retrouve avec des réformes plus dures
qu'elles ne leur a été parce que moins
progressif parce qu'on n'a pas le temps
de s'adapter et on est en train
aujourd'hui de payer le prix de la
lâcheté dont on a fait preuve pendant 10
ans et si les Français sont mécontents
c'est pas parce qu'on réforme les
retraites à mon avis c'est parce qu'on
ne les a pas assez réformé
progressivement pour qu'elle soit moins
douloureuse
un vote qui a eu lieu à cette nuit c'est
le vote de l'article 2 sur l'index
senior les députés l'ont rejeté et une
quarantaine de députés les républicains
ont rejeté l'instauration de cette index
senior vous comprenez ce vote oui parce
que cette disposition qui malgré tout
pour faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps en entreprise pour garder
davantage les seniors en entreprise
n'a qu'une valeur informative il
s'agissait de mesurer l'évolution de la
présence des salariés les moins jeunes
ou les plus âgés dans l'entreprise et
uniquement pour les grandes entreprises
ceci est un instrument qui aide à la
décision mais ça n'est pas une
contrainte exercée sur l'entreprise pour
le maintien des seniors dans
l'entreprise et on voit mal pourquoi on
met une disposition de ce genre dans une
loi dont je vous rappelle qu'elle
s'appelle loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale je connais bien ses
lois puisque c'est le gouvernement
d'Alain Juppé en 1996 qui a révisé la
Constitution pour qui est d'un côté le
budget de l'État de l'autre le budget de
la Sécurité sociale et de la retraite et
ces lois sont faites pour équilibrer les
recettes et les dépenses alors cette
mesure est-ce qu'elle sert à équilibrer
les recettes et les dépenses les députés
ont fini par se dire c'est intéressant
certainement de créer cet instrument on
n'a pas besoin de la loi pour le faire
et encore moins d'une loi de financement
je vais vous dire je ne dis pas que la
mesure est inutile mais je dis qu'elle
n'a rien à faire dans un texte de cette
nature et d'ailleurs si à parlementaire
faisait un amendement pour la créer il
n'est pas certain que le Conseil
constitutionnel ne l'annulerait pas en
disant mais ça n'a rien à faire dans une
loi de financement donc de la sécurité
sociale je le croiseur était voté je le
crois un dernier mot puisque Aurélien
Pradier qu'on entend beaucoup a été mis
en minorité hier lors du bureau
politique de votre partie qui a voté à
la grande majorité son soutien à la
réforme est-ce qu'il peut continuer à
exprimer autant ses réticences sur le
texte en étant vice-président mais c'est
une question qui se pose il y a
maintenant très clairement et plus
encore depuis hier matin une ligne
politique de LR
sur un sujet un peu périphérique on peut
comprendre que chacun avance avec sa
propre opinion quand il s'agit d'assurer
d'un sujet central pour la vie de la
nation et il me semble que la retraite
touche tous les Français que donc un
sujet central pour la vie de la nation
alors on prend ces responsabilités
monsieur Pradier et parlementaire il a
parfaitement le droit d'avoir des
positions autonomes mais il n'a pas le
droit de s'exprimer au nom de LR donc
c'est quoi il doit quitter il doit
quitter
ça veut dire que au moment
de vérité du vote de la réforme s'il
n'est pas sur la ligne 2 LR il n'a
aucune qualification pour être le
porte-parole de LR ça c'est certain donc
quitté la direction mais il peut rester
au sein du parti mais écoutez au sein du
parti chacun peut avoir son opinion
propre mais il faut clair pour les
Français les Français ça les trouble de
se dire mais alors ce parti
quelle est sa position c'est celle de
Monsieur Pradier c'est celle qui a été
votée par son bureau politique et bien
je réponds c'est celle qui a été votée
par son bureau politique et ce qui n'ont
pas la même position ne parle pas
des républicains pardon il a fait bilan
je crois en effet qu'à un moment de
donner des voies discordantes sur un
sujet essentiel qui est un vrai marqueur
politique n'ont pas leur place à la
direction du parti je suis assez ferme
là-dessus et c'est très clair on va
passer à l'actualité du Sénat puisque
hier vous avez additionné Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur sur
la réforme de la police judiciaire on
voit ça avec Audrey betas
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour et Audrey Gérald
Darmanin était donc auditionné hier par
la commission des Lois du Sénat dans le
cadre d'une mission d'information sur
l'organisation de la police judiciaire
c'était une sorte de points d'État oui
car vous le savez le ministre de
l'Intérieur porte un grand projet de
réforme de la police nationale et par
voie de conséquence de la police
judiciaire et c'est ce point qui
cristallise l'inquiétude des syndicats
ils ont notamment peur con on enlève des
moyens à l'APJ qui s'occupe normalement
du grand banditisme pour les affecter
aux affaires courantes ça a donné lieu à
plusieurs rapports le premier de
l'Assemblée nationale il y en a aussi un
du Sénat avec les travaux de votre
collègue philippe Dominati des rapports
aussi des inspections générales de la
justice et de la police nationale le
tout avant les conclusions d'une mission
d'information du Sénat à ce sujet bref
il était temps de poser un peu les
choses à plat et de rassurer le ministre
l'a rappelé à plusieurs reprises il
assure que l'APJ restera bien dans son
rôle écoutez
pas les utiliser voilà quand vous avez
la chance d'avoir de grands artistes
vous les voulez vous les mettez pas
évidemment à faire à faire autre chose
bien sûr dans la semaine si j'ose dire
c'est la sécurité publique il doit avoir
un petit peu peur de cette réforme parce
que c'est pas contrairement à ce que
pense la PJ la PJ qui sera omnie au
service de la sécurité publique mais
l'inverse c'est les agences de sécurité
publique qui sont beaucoup plus nombreux
qui seront plus utilisés par la PJ pour
faire des interpellations et ça laisse
au policiers du spectre les grandes
affaires mais ils utilisent les
policiers qui ne sont pas des policiers
de spécialisés de préjudiciaires
concourir à la faire parce que pour
faire des perquises vous avez pas besoin
d'avoir toujours des policiers du haut
du spectre
est-ce que vous pensez que les propos du
ministre de l'intérieur sont en mesure
de rassurer les syndicats
je n'en suis pas certain
d'ailleurs il reconnaît lui-même que la
police judiciaire
dans son ensemble n'est pas favorable
à certaines modalités de cette réforme
les réformes de l'administration
relèvent du ministre nous Parlement nous
les contrôlons parce que nous avons une
mission constitutionnelle de contrôle ce
qui nous inquiète dans cette réforme
c'est
l'impact qu'elle peut avoir sur
l'exécution des enquêtes sous l'autorité
des procureurs d'une part et des juges
d'instruction de l'autre c'est la
disponibilité de la police judiciaire
pour l'accomplissement de tous ces actes
d'enquêtes or vous le savez bien les
violences sur les personnes ne cessent
d'augmenter la délinquance s'aggrave et
les vocations des policiers qui
rejoignaient avec fierté jusqu'à
jusqu'aux années récentes la police
judiciaire et bien le fond de moins en
moins
pourquoi
c'est parce que il y a d'énormes
contraintes dans la vie personnelle de
chacun dans ce métier d'enquêteur alors
qu'il est intellectuellement très
intéressant très motivant sur le plan du
service de la nation il y a aujourd'hui
un problème de vocation alors vous
prenez ce problème de vocation vous
faites une réorganisation qui jette le
trouble les procureurs et les magistrats
s'inquiètent vous ne pouvez pas
considérer que tout est bien j'ai bien
entendu aussi le directeur général de la
police nationale c'est un homme qui est
très proche des policiers qui a fait un
travail tout à fait remarquable pour
réorganiser mais je crois qu'il y a dans
cette réforme une sorte d'angle mort et
ça n'est pas simplement des propos suave
qui vont corriger cette impression que
l'on prend un risque sur l'organisation
des services enquêteurs avec cette
réforme je crois qu'il faut remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier afin d'apporter
non seulement en paroles mais aussi en
acte des réponses aux attentes
est-ce que le ministre est d'accord pour
avoir sa copine en tout cas il a fait
quelques petites annonces hier il n'est
pas fermé à l'idée de créer une filière
judiciaire nationale comme le propose le
Sénat ou l'assemblée il est aussi
d'accord pour reprendre 19
préconisations des inspections générales
à la lumière des expérimentations qui
ont déjà eu lieu en outre-mer et sur la
géographie d'action de la PJ il est
aussi d'accord pour faire un geste un
petit affaire rappelle pardon avec la
réforme beaucoup craignent que la PJ
soit cloisonnée à l'échelle du
département alors que le crime organisé
et mondialisé et se complexifie écoutait
la réponse du ministre
moi j'entends ce que disent ce qui
conteste dire bah voilà la Direction
Départementale la police nationale pour
nous ça va pas dans certains
départements parce que c'est trop petit
alors j'ai toujours eu dit que c'était
ma vocation régionale raisonnable mais
les manifestement je m'exprime mal ou je
suis malentendu où on n'a pas tout à
fait donc ce que je vais propose
peut-être en m'inspirant de des rapports
à la fois du ministère du Sénat et
l'Assemblée c'est que je proposais aux
organisations syndicales de faire des
propositions de modifications voilà s'il
pense qu'il y a un périmètre de PJ qui
peut être légèrement différent que ce
qu'on a imaginé mais en regardant le
et puis un dernier point Oriane qui a
été mis en lumière par cette audition et
surtout par la réforme ce sont les
stocks les stocks ce sont les affaires
non traitées il y en aurait en France
plus d'un million 500 000 alors le
ministre a tenté une explication écouté
la difficulté que nous avons elle est
importante c'est que nous avons une
multiplicité désormais de contentieux et
bien sûr les violences conjugales ont
complètement changé la façon de
fonctionner la police et ta gendarmerie
puisque nous avons dit les armes
policiers aux gendarmes non seulement
vous ne prenez plus aucune main courante
mais vous déposez tout en plainte ou en
ouverture si c'est un signalement pour
que le procureur de la République puisse
faire évidemment une poursuite et par
ailleurs vous vous concentrez sur les
plaintes physiques les plantes qui
touchent les personnes et on verra les
plaintes des biens plus tard je
caricatures mais c'est grosso modo
Sherlock comprend que il vaut mieux
s'occuper des personnes que des biens
quand on doit faire deux urgences du
coup les stocks c'est surtout des stocks
de bien
surtout des stocks de bien mais quand
même Philippe a un million 500 000
affaires m'ont traité en France ces
phénoménal
et ça interroge sur la capacité d'une
grande démocratie à porter ses moyens à
la hauteur des attentes de la population
parce que par les stocks par les flux
ces technocratiques en réalité derrière
ceci il y a quand même des plaintes de
personnes de personnes qui ont des
motifs de demander secours
à la police et à la justice donc on ne
peut pas se satisfaire d'une telle
situation et même si le ministre dit
abeyron maintenant mieux fait comprendre
en cas de violence conjugales que il
faut ne pas se contenter d'une main
courante mais bien sûr créer une plainte
mais il suffit pas en quelque sorte de
se plaindre qu'il y a plus de plaintes
enregistrés pour les violences
conjugales il faut se mettre en mesure
que les enquêtes aient lieu et que les
poursuites se fassent
merci Audrey merci à tout à l'heure oui
on va parler de la réforme et peut-être
d'une possibilité pour les pour les
paramédicaux de faire des actes à la
place des médecins
merci beaucoup Audrey à tout à l'heure
on va aller voir l'actualité dans nos
régions du côté de Poitiers
on retrouve Philippe Blanchard on
retrouve Delphine Blanchard pardon la
Nouvelle République journal fine merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et en une
Delphine vous nous proposez un reportage
sur les détenus en fin de peine qui
serait insert oui tout à fait Roger et
Édouard sont arrivés le 12 janvier 2023
Youssef le 26 janvier ces trois détenus
en fin de peine sont les premiers
résidents de la ferme Emmaüs
Maisoncelles en pleine campagne près de
Lusignan à quelques kilomètres de
Poitiers dans la Vienne avant de
recouvrer leur liberté ils vont
travailler à la réinsertion encadrée par
une équipe de professionnels et de
bénévoles le projet a été prononcé en
2020 imaginez sur le même modèle de
fermer mahus quand Picardie pour la
réinsertion des personnes détenues en
fin de peine le placement à l'extérieur
a prouvé son efficacité et ce type de
structure n'existait pas dans la région
a explique ce matin dans nos colonnes
Bruno vautin le fondateur et le
directeur de la ferme alors quelle est
l'ambition de ce projet en relation avec
l'administration pénitentiaire CDD
durant 6 à 18 mois les résidents à
préparer un nouveau projet de vie à
l'extérieur ou est-ce que je vais
m'installer dans quel type de logement
quoi faire comme activité
professionnelle comment accéder à mes
droits comment retrouver des repères
familiaux et amicaux comment retrouver
en somme une autonomie après une longue
européenne de prison un quatrième
résident doit arriver en mars prochain
il devrait être huit fin 2023 et 12 au
total fin 2024 ce lieu ouvert a été
financé à hauteur de 700 000 euros Roger
a 57 ans Yousse 22 et ils expliquent
dans nos colonnes ce que ça leur a fait
de retrouver le goût de la liberté l'un
des deux racontes qu'il faut se
réhabituer à la vie en communauté se
respecter les uns les autres et il
essaye d'en rigoler sinon je sais bien
que ça sera vite le retour à la case
départ d'une petite fille Youssef quand
elle lui est le plus jeune des résidents
il explique c'est un prof qui nous a
présenté ce projet en détention j'ai
fait une lettre de candidature le
feeling est bien passé lors du premier
rendez-vous d'entretien ça me plaisait
comparer au bracelet électronique là
j'ai un travail un logement une aide
sociale monsieur le sénateur j'ai une
question pour vous selon vous ces
structures devraient-elles se
généraliser sur tout le territoire pour
une meilleure réintégration des détenus
en fin de peine est-ce que ça vous
semble être une bonne idée
à question simple réponse claire la
réponse est oui évidemment ce qui est
presque stupéfiant dans une grande
démocratie comme la France c'est qu'on
en soit à se poser ce genre de questions
le système pénitentiel allemand
réalise déjà cette qualité de
préparation du retour à la vie civile
nous notre débat
en matière de politique pénitentiaire et
politique pénale c'est
augmenter les peines mais ce qui assure
la sécurité des Français c'est pas la
durée de la peine
c'est la manière dont les détenus
sortant de prison va se réinsérer ou
récidiver on entend parfois dire la
prison c'est l'école du crime ou du de
la délinquance c'est un peu vrai parfois
malgré les efforts de d'administration
pénitentiaire la générosité de nos
surveillance mais le service
pénitentiaire en France est un grand
service public délaissé il y a trop de
sorties qu'on qualifie de sortie sèches
la protection de la société et
l'humanisme qui doit nous inspirer
commande l'une et l'autre d'avoir une
politique de réinsertion qui commence
par la formation le soin parfois en
prison le travail en prison et puis
surtout en fin de peine des une
généralisation
des
adaptations
de la détention à une sortie progressive
il faut pas que le détenu au fil des
années soit de plus en plus désinséré il
faut l'inverse c'est-à-dire qu'au fil
des années et soit de mieux en mieux
insérable alors on réussit pas toujours
je ne suis pas naïf il ne faut pas
s'imaginer que
par un coup de baguette magique on va
faire des citoyens modèles à partir de
délinquant ou de criminels
qui sont enracinés dans leur marginalité
mais
renoncer par avance pas tout à fait le
cas je veux pas non plus exagérer mais
j'essaye de me faire comprendre renoncer
par avant à préparer la réinsertion
professionnelle familial par les
relations avec la famille quand elle
subsiste
et avoir une progressivité dans le
départ de la prison être dans des
établissements de semis liberté tout
ceci doit être développé
quantitativement nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de place en prison elles
sont saturées il y a eu des promesses il
y a 6 ans elles n'ont pas été tenues de
création de 16000 places de prison et je
ne veux pas dire des places de prison de
haute sécurité je veux aussi dire des
places dans des établissements
intermédiaires entre la prison
traditionnelle et la liberté donc
quantitativement on n'a pas fait le
travail
qualitativement malgré encore une fois
la qualité humaine de nos services
pénitentiaires et des services de
réinsertion nous n'avons pas les moyens
humains d'accompagnement et je crois que
ça c'est vital et les Français doivent
se dire ils ne suffit pas d'allonger une
peine de prison dans le code pénal de 5
ans à 10 ans pour régler nos problèmes
de sécurité la sécurité elle viendra de
la qualité de la réinsertion justement
un mot là-dessus puisque la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale
examine aujourd'hui une proposition de
loi du groupe horizon donc de la
majorité présidentielle pour mieux
lutter contre la récidive il entend
notamment établir les peines plancher
pour certains délits de violences commis
en récidive est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée la sévérité
est un des volets de l'action pénale
mais comme j'ai essayé de l'expliquer
avec beaucoup de convictions ça n'est
qu'un des volets et c'est peut-être pas
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est trop
facile d'avoir un succès d'estime auprès
des Français en leur disant en cas
précises je vais aggraver les peines par
les peines planchers on en a fait
l'expérience ça effectivement permis de
réhausser le niveau des peines ça peut
avoir un caractère dissuasif mais
reconnaissons-le le caractère dissuasif
existe déjà quand on est à 50 prisons et
quand on passe à 7 ans il existe encore
mais ça ne change pas la face du monde
pour le délinquant donc attention
à ne pas avoir une politique qui
consiste uniquement à aggraver les
peines on peut l'envisager dans certains
cas tout en ayant une bonne échelle de
peine mais il faut mettre le paquet si
j'ose dire sur la préparation de la
sortie car c'est là que le danger vient
et si vous condamnez à 7 ans au lieu de
5 ans vous aurez toujours le problème de
la sortie on
va amen merci beaucoup Delphine d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin on regarde la Une
de La Nouvelle République des détenus
envoyer à la ferme à Lusignan c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Delphine Blanchard un dernier mot sur un
autre sujet Emmanuel Macron planche sur
la réforme des institutions il s'est
entretenu avec Gérard Larcher lundi
est-ce que c'est le moment de lancer ce
chantier pour vous
il n'y a pas de mauvais moment pour
améliorer le fonctionnement de notre
démocratie je crois qu'au cours des
dernières années il a plutôt été dégradé
qu'améliorée je pense que dans une
réforme des institutions il faut faire
deux choses
rééquilibrer pourquoi est-ce que le
président Macron c'est à plusieurs
reprises et au corps aujourd'hui trouver
tout seul face à la foule je veux dire
la foule pour ne pas dire le peuple
parce que certaines personnes pensent
qu'il suffit d'être la foule pour
pouvoir représenter le peuple ça n'est
pas le cas mais pourquoi le président de
la République se retrouve tout seul tout
simplement parce qu'il a organisé
lui-même son isolement avec si une sorte
d'unité fonctionnelle président
gouvernement majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale qui lui donne les pleins
pouvoirs il faut qu'il y ait des
contre-pouvoirs il faut qu'il y ait un
équilibre et d'équilibre fondamental il
vient du fait que le Parlement joue
pleinement son rôle aujourd'hui le Sénat
joue pleinement son rôle mais le
Parlement globalement ne le joue pas
suffisamment donc le premier impératif
si on veut que une réforme soit
démocratiquement utile c'est de
renforcer le pouvoir du Parlement il y a
un deuxième impératif c'est de lutter
contre le centralisme et l'étatisme qui
sont le propre de la culture politique
française et je crois véritablement que
renforcer les libertés locales renforcer
la commune renforcer nos départements en
région peut-être aussi c'est un
impératif démocratique et il y a un
troisième élément
arrêtons de raconter des histoires aux
gens la démocratie ça n'est pas une
centaine d'hommes et de femmes
sélectionnées
à partir d'un échantillon
qui a été mis au point par les
organismes de sondage pour
prétendre que il représente le peuple
c'est un attrape nigaud la convention
citoyenne sans personne représente la
France alors qu'elles sont pas élues
vous feriez un sondage avec 100
personnes que dirait la commission des
sondages elle vous dirait ce sondage
n'est pas valable vous devez maintenant
publier dans la presse des démentis aux
résultats qu'il a qu'il a fait
apparaître donc
revenons fondamentaux de la démocratie
représentative et puis utilisons le
référendum de temps en temps monsieur
Macron a peur du référendum et ça
contribue à l'isoler aussi merci
Philippe merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous on vous reviendrait nous voir
prochainement parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de textes
merci beaucoup si vous acceptez merci
d'avoir été avec nous minutes dans le
cas des territoires on reparlera de la
réforme des retraites un examen se
poursuit à l'Assemblée nationale l'index
senior a été rejeté premier revers pour
le gouvernement on en parle tout de
suite avec notre prochaine invité c'est
Sébastien Chenu